[Música]
la policía francesa arrestó a nueve
personas relacionadas con la
decapitación de un maestro francés en
una calle de los suburbios de parís el
gobierno dijo que su respuesta será la
más firme contra el acto terrorista
perpetrado presuntamente por un joven de
18 años luego de que el profesor
mostrara en clase una caricatura del
profeta mahoma
los laboristas de ella sin arder
vencieron en las parlamentarias de nueva
zelanda con 49 de los apoyos frente a
27% de los nacionalistas los votantes
recompensaron una respuesta decisiva al
hobby 19 y la política de 40 años podría
formar el primer gobierno de partido
único en décadas
y este domingo bolivia repite las
elecciones anuladas hace casi un año por
denuncias de fraude contra el ex
presidente de evo morales- hoy en
argentina el mandatario no está entre
los candidatos so pero su influencia
sigue siendo determinante en el destino
del país
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información más importante de américa
latina y del mundo en france 24
iniciamos en francia porque hay luto y
conmoción después del atentado
terrorista en el que un maestro falleció
decapitado horas después de mostrar en
una clase sobre libertad de expresión
una caricatura del profeta mahoma el
presunto agresor es un joven chileno de
18 años la escena que tuvo lugar en una
calle de los suburbios de parís terminó
con la muerte del presunto atacante a
tiros por parte de la policía
el presidente de manuel macro visitó la
zona y aseguró que el terrorismo no
pasará por encima de la democracia entre
tanto nueve personas fueron arrestadas
en la investigación del crimen aquí les
mostramos testimonios de la comunidad
estudiantil y de los padres de familia
que ya iniciaron las conmemoraciones
sus habitantes lo describen como un
pueblo tranquilo la comuna de confianza
antonio erin fue golpeada por un hecho
violento este viernes los profesores que
trabajan en este sector están asombrados
y los padres de los alumnos
profundamente molestos tenemos 15 días
para reconstruirnos un poco y
tranquilizaran pequeños es algo
complicado por suerte la escuela ya
había terminado los estudiantes también
están traumatizados
no era mi maestro pero lo había visto me
sorprende porque nunca más volveré a
verlo el asombro y la indignación
también se toma la clase política este
sábado el ministro de educación nacional
jean-michel blanca se reunirá con
representantes del personal y los padres
de los estudiantes esta noche la
república es atacada con el asesinato de
uno de sus servidores un profesor esta
noche pienso en él en su familia nuestra
unidad y firmeza son las únicas
respuestas a la monstruosidad del
terrorismo islamista
varios políticos condenaron unánimamente
del ataque
la laborista ya sin darme declara su
victoria en las elecciones de nueva
zelanda seguirá al frente del gobierno
tras unos comicios parlamentarios en los
que no sólo derrotó cómodamente a los
nacionalistas con 49 % contra 27% de
apoyos sino que además podrá ser la
primera en formar gobierno con un
partido único en décadas desde 1996 un
partido no obtenía tantos escaños y es
que los laboristas con casi el 80% de
los votos escrutados lograran al menos
64 de 120 puestos en el parlamento
unicameral los ciudadanos recompensaron
a la política de 40 años sólo por su
respuesta a la pandemia y también por el
manejo del ataque terrorista del año
pasado en christchurch también se
votaron referendos para legalizar la
eutanasia y la marihuana recreativa con
nosotros desde madrid hasta carlos
fernández analista internacional carlos
buen día para usted
pregunto estas elecciones son
considerados históricas para nueva
zelanda
la proporción de escaños es la más alta
desde los 90 que representa esto para
los laboristas
hola buenos días es un éxito total para
el partido laborista para ellas indagar
en ya que es la victoria más grande que
han conseguido en los últimos 25 años es
un gobierno que van a formar sin ningún
tipo de alianza para gobernar en
solitario y desde luego el pueblo la
beneficiado debido a la gestión de la
y de mí
posible
prueba
vimos nacer
tenemos problemas con la comunicación
pero vamos a continuar con más noticias
entretanto aquí en esta mañana en france
24 y es que el 17 de octubre de 2019
hace un año se marcó el inicio de un
levantamiento masivo de la población
libanesa contra sus élites políticas
acusadas de incompetencia y de
corrupción ese movimiento causó la
salida de dos primeros ministros y
rompió los tabús anclados a la sociedad
como la demanda del fin del
confesionalismo e incluso el aumento de
los derechos para las mujeres y las
minorías sexuales pero un año después la
clase política sigue en el poder y el
país sigue sigue cayendo en la crisis
dos contenedores de basura en llamas en
las calles de beirut aquel 17 de octubre
los libaneses protestan en contra de un
impuesto por el uso de la aplicación de
mensajería de whatsapp ellos no lo
sabían pero en las horas siguientes
millones de compatriotas se unirían a
ellos al día siguiente los manifestantes
comenzaron a gritar revolución y las
protestas se extienden en todo el país
en frente del palacio del primer
ministro se levanta el eslogan de las
revoluciones árabes
de todos salvar a todos del más
importante al menos importante ellos nos
robaron a tres días después ya son medio
millón de personas por primera vez en la
historia del país los libaneses de todas
las religiones marcharon juntos en
contra de sus dirigentes y reclaman un
cambio de régimen tras la renuncia de
hariri y reemplazado por un casi
desconocido
hasan diab las calles están llenas de
manifestantes los miembros de su
gobierno presentados como independientes
son en realidad elegidos por las fuerzas
políticas tradicionales
el fin de semana del 18 de enero cerca
de 550 personas resultaron heridos
bajo el mandato de hasan diab la
economía se desploma la moneda nacional
pierde el 100% de su valor y el gobierno
no alcanza un acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional muchos libaneses
no manifestaron más
el 4 de agosto se dio lo impensable dos
mil setecientos cincuenta toneladas de
nitrato de amonio descuidadas por las
autoridades explotan en el puerto de
beirut la catástrofe dejó más de 200
muertos y 6.500 heridos
la explosión revive la respuesta social
y causó la renuncia del primer ministro
hasan diab
luego de dos visitas al líbano en menos
de un mes el presidente francés emmanuel
mccomb presionó a los dirigentes a
formar un nuevo gobierno sin éxito un
año después del inicio de la revolución
algunos contestatarios intentan mantener
viva la llama del movimiento que amenaza
con extinguirse la clase política de
siempre todavía está en el poder
y volvemos a nueva zelanda ya
recuperamos la comunicación con nuestro
analista carlos fernández carlos quiero
pasar ya a la segunda pregunta que le
tenía preparada y es que si bien arden
la premiaron por el manejo del gobi 19
por la maneja el manejo de la crisis en
christchurch en ella prometió para el
período anterior que iba a hacer
transformaciones que iban a ser
progresivas durante su mandato estos
cambios no se lograron y además quedaron
frenados por la pandemia en qué
consistirían y cómo sería el desafío
para cumplirlos en este nuevo período
legislativo
bien es un gran desafío ya que el país
ahora mismo está sumido en la
recuperación es lo más importante para
ellos sí es cierto que ya se ha
prometido la construcción de miles de
viviendas para los más desfavorecidos y
un plan para la reducción de pobreza
infantil
estos son planes que se han quedado en
el tintero debido a la situación a la
situación de crisis pero bueno es algo
que tienen que enfrentar porque son
promesas que han proclamado por otro
lado para los próximos cinco años ha
prometido que el cien por cien de las
energías que va a emplear al país sean
energías totalmente renovables así como
que en un periodo de aquí a 2025 todos
los plásticos difíciles de reciclar
serán retirados del uso y del mercado
entonces bueno se enfrentan es en este
momento a ese tipo de respuestas
y finalmente también se votó en esta
jornada un referendo por la marihuana
medicinal y la eutanasia se podría
convertir nueva zelanda en el tercer
país del mundo en aprobar la utilización
de la marihuana medicinal pero solamente
hasta el 30 de octubre vamos a conocer
los resultados usted qué opina de la
posibilidad de que se dé la aprobación
bueno dada la situación la verdad hay
una alta probabilidad de que estas
proposiciones salgan adelante
si bien el partido laboralista nos ha
posible que no oficialmente ante ambos
referendos el par que conservamos si lo
ha hecho o si vamos en contra de ellos
pero son iniciativas que ha promovido
sobre todo el partido progresista el
partido laboralista que ha alcanzado la
mayoría absoluta por lo tanto se estima
que estas propuestas con alta
probabilidad de éxito sí que saldrán
adelante
carlos fernández analista internacional
desde madrid gracias a usted por estar
con nosotros y cambiamos de tema
azerbaiyán y armenia se acusaron
mutuamente de nuevos ataques en
violación de una inefectiva tregua
negociada por rusia bakú dijo que 13
civiles murieron y más de 50 resultaron
heridos en la ciudad de ganja por un
ataque con misiles armenios mientras que
ereván acusó a azerbaiyán de continuar
con los bombardeos la lucha es la peor
en la región desde que azerbaiyán y las
fuerzas de etnia armenia entraron en
guerra en la década de 1990 por nagorno
karabaj a un territorio montañoso
reconocido internacionalmente como parte
de azerbaiyán pero poblado y gobernado
por personas de la etnia armenia
sigue la campaña electoral en eeuu el
presidente de donald trump se dirige hoy
a michigan y wisconsin última parada
antes de lanzar una gira por los estados
del oeste para conquistar votantes y es
que el demócrata joe biden sigue
superándolo en las encuestas nacionales
trump se mueve rápidamente tratando de
asegurar los estados que hace cuatro
años ganó el republicano se impuso en
michigan y wisconsin en 2016 pero las
encuestas de este año hablan de forma
diferente y lo muestran detrás de byd en
el ex vicepresidente por su parte quien
ha intensificado los viajes en las
últimas semanas planea permanecer hoy en
su estado natal de delaware no así con
su compañera de fórmula la senadora
kamala harris de california quien te
está evitando viajar durante algunos
días después de que su asistente
contrajo kobe 19
y vamos a américa latina' falta un día
para las elecciones en bolivia este
domingo se elegirá al nuevo presidente
junto a senadores y diputados 173
millones de ciudadanos están llamados a
votar a casi un año de la anulación de
los comicios por denuncias de fraude del
ex presidente evo morales que aunque
dejo bolivia hace 11 meses y está
exiliado en argentina paradójicamente
está muy presente en la política del
país que gobernó por casi 14 años el
siguiente es un informe de nuestra
corresponsal en bolivia mery vaca
no hay un día sin que evo morales-
irrumpa en la campaña de bolivia desde
argentina el ex gobernante también es el
jefe de campaña del movimiento al
socialismo y sus adversarios afirman que
tendrá el verdadero poder si luisa se
gana los comicios del país solamente
luchó será presidente de bolivia con
todas las atribuciones y
responsabilidades que eso significa
confío totalmente pero la sombra de
morales es muy fuerte y muchas cosas que
dice causan revuelo en bolivia el
candidato del movimiento al socialismo
tuvo que decir que no comparte con evo
morales que la prensa sea el enemigo
número uno pero es un pensamiento del
compañero nadie puede nadie puede
decirle lo que piensa él siempre ha
tuiteado lo que él piensa pero nosotros
tenemos un criterio diferente aunque las
diferencias entre los dos parecen
mínimas cuando se refieren al rol de los
periodistas no los periodistas tienen
que ponerse la camiseta rapaz y
recuperamos la parte para los bolivianos
sus adversarios no creen que evo morales
mantenga distancia del poder si ar se
triunfa
el candidato centrista que viene segundo
en las encuestas dice que votar por luís
arce será igual que votar por evo
morales
bien
[Música]
a mí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
para el partido de derecha creemos
tercero en las encuestas
arze fue elegido por morales como
candidato para protegerlo de las
denuncias de corrupción en su contra es
la persona que ha puesto a dedo morales
ayma para que puedan protegerle todos
los actos de corrupción tras casi 14
años en el poder el domingo los
bolivianos dirán si evo morales
continuará o no marcando el futuro de la
política del país y para finalizar vamos
a méjico los progress cultores de la
tradicional flor de cempasúchil están
preocupados por las restricciones en
medio de la pandemia y es que se acerca
en la emblemática celebración del día de
muertos en el país azteca y esta flor no
puede faltar en los adornos de las
tumbas de los seres queridos pero con el
aislamiento y con el cierre de los
cementerios son los floricultores ya se
preparan para vender - algunos tratarán
de conservar la tradición y de llevar
las flores a los hogares para llamar con
su aroma a los seres queridos como dicta
la tradición
hasta aquí el informativo volvemos en
minutos con más información en france 24
feliz sábado
[Música]